Donald Trump's calendar is filling up
the former U.S president found out his
arraignment on Election interference
charges in Georgia will be September 6th
and at this courthouse in Washington it
was decided he will go on trial for
conspiring to steal the 2020
presidential election on March the 4th
next year the decision came in a hearing
that lasted just over 90 minutes Donald
Trump's defense wanted to delay the
process by more than two years saying
with millions of documents to review
they wanted a trial date in April 2026
the prosecution wanted to proceed on
January the 2nd next year the judge
Tanya chutkin said both dates were
unacceptable both outside the normal
windows for scheduling a trial Donald
Trump's team accused the prosecution of
pursuing a show trial but left without
making any comment on the outcome the
decision by judge Tanya chutkin could
upend the 2024 Republican Presidential
nomination fight the trial starts the
day before super Tuesday when voters in
more than a dozen states cast their
ballot in the primary races and comes
just three weeks before Donald Trump
will be back in court in New York
charged with paying hush money to an
adult film star I think going into Super
Tuesday I think their their minds will
already be made up and I think these
these court cases are not going to sway
primary voters one way or other uh they
already know who Donald Trump is and
many of them have already gotten behind
him on his true social media platform
Donald Trump wrote Today a biased
trump-hating judge gave me only a
two-month extension just what our
corrupt government wanted I will appeal
Trump insists the cases the charges
against them are election interference
and he is innocent now he has a firm
date of when he gets the chance to prove
that Alan Fisher Al Jazeera Washington
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera